skRRRRRatta DUEUAUEUEUAUE
förlorar du mAAAnnEEEn
*epic explosion*
Ho... Hold on hold on one second
CLEAN ALERT 3x
AaAAh, These mirrors aren't clean, What's wrong with these mirrors?!
WHY HE IS NOT CLEANING THE MI- RrrrRRRrrrrRRRRR
That's what you sound like, are you happy now?
Mirror is clean.
Let's begin the challenge
The rule is simple
Skratta du, forlorar du
Ok manen? *swedish words*
LETS  GO
*Pewds laughs*
Oh...
That's great
That's great. I know this I have a little-
(look at papa pewds cleaning)
Am I unironically cleaning while I'm p-*laugh*
tHeRe WaS a SmUdgE iN tHe ScReEn
Oh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Why is Alabama ok with this and not the gay rat wedding?
so disappointing
Hey look, more MARVEL memes
just what we needed
"I've seen the footage. You owe me-"
GODDAMNIT WHAT IS THIS PICTURE?!
I love it, brofist if you're gay too
Come on, gays
the rest have to wait for 100 mil
but the real gay bros
you get the fist now
What can I say? I'm just inclusive like that ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
But ONLY gay peopl-
*laugh*
Pewds reading: "Is the mic that bad?"
Oh god, does he have one of the Blue Yeti mics? (maybe)
They're worse than my microphones (you don't say?)
*laugh*
Yeah it's-no it sounds GREAT
I swear to God (no swearing)
It is the Blue Yeti, isn't it?
It only works if you're in an isolated room
Right?
Yeah people love it for some reason
It's such a piece of ****
A-it's a hundred pound microphone and it sounds
a w f u l, alright?
yOu WaNt ThIs KiNd Of MiCrOpHoNe
*rip ears* I CARE ABOUT QUALITY!!
(;-;) QUALITY
QUALI- I don't know how this sounds
Does this sound bad? (yes)
I can't tell
Alright so far no skratta
We're doing pretty good
Brofist if-
no..(;-;)
He-How he kept a straight face how?
News Anchor: "Still some fans didn't get the memo"
Oh no, not the Cardi B concert..
*skratta*
"Well throughout the evening,
Cardi B fans who rolled up here to the El Paso County Coliseum
went from feeling OKURR with anticipation
to feeling rrrr with disappointment
*lots of skrattas*
GOOD I didn't skratta, VERY GOOD
Why does Cardi B exist?
She's so annoying and I hate her
Listen. Don't judge me, I need to clean
New space~
There's smudges everywhere
Gotta make-
Sorry guys, got the made (?) shirts clean
otherwise, I will get 500,000 COMMENTS
about how my mirr-
There's a spot there, isn't it? (where?)
Where?
There? is it here?
did I get it?
dID I GET IT?!?!
DID I GET IT???
*explosion*
next time I clean your face
okay?
Don't think I wont do it mother fricker
*footsteps*
Pewds reading: Sneak Zero
Oh, I've seen this...
*chuckle*
I'm laughing even though (?)
*banging sounds*
Oh, its so good
I love the "boom" that comes in the middle as well
its beautiful editing
10 out of 10
*more banging*
*laugh*
I miss Dark Souls, its an epic game
too bad im not a g- nerdy gamer anymore
dumby nerdy game
*gibberish*
its him again!
excuse me?
*mumbles* that chicken....
*laugh*
God Damn it
*giggle*
(pewds imitating that one vine) look at all those chickens!
is that real?
*HEFTY LAUGH*
is that a chicken?
oh god I laugh at the worst (censored)
All right
moving on
Oh God, its about to get worse
*Sudden screams*
STOP
Does this guy just keep on making these types of clips now?
is he milking this for the memes?
okay, I respect it
Pewds reading loudly: Will you give me Blowjob?
Smile = yes
Blowjob = No
*chuckle*
So stupid!
Pewds reading: Its a simple spell, but quite unbreakable.